Society has been telling single mothers
for decades now you're strong you're
independent you don't need no man until
they need child support or until they
need government handouts they still have
the opportunity to raise children but
without the authority of a man in a
household and the problem with that is
that single mommy households tend to be
absolute beta factories they don't churn
out strong virtuous men and they
generally churn out promiscuous [__]
women the vast majority of gang activity
single parent household vast majority of
teenage pregnancies vast majority of
suicide attempts two-parent households
with a man and a woman produce far more
useful members of society than ones that
are walking around virtuously pounding
their chest saying I am awesome here's
my Offspring the vast majority of the
guys that watch my content come from
single parent households they haven't
got it right and they've been
conditioned to be kind humble nice these
bombs generally turn out weak men that
try to enter the friend zone to get with
the gals and women don't want weak
pussified men they want strong virtuous
guys that's what they've always been
attracted to men compete women's shoes